Mm.
It doesn't take long.
When you start to develop a practice of
mindfulness before you realize that we
are virtually continually bombarded by
thoughts.
It's the,
I like weather patterns in the mind.
The legs said there are some times like
nice clear sunny days,
but there are an awful lot of cloudy
days,
tumultuous days,
rainy days,
turbulent,
stormy weather.
And again,
challenges.
How are we to be in relationship to all
of that stuff that's driving our lives
and our narrative of who I am.
And,
and so,
um,
when
you
get in touch with
what awareness really is,
then you're,
the first thing you realize is that
those thoughts are not me and they're
not mine.
They're just like weather patterns.
Yeah.
Impersonal weather patterns in the mind.
So then you can observe them like a
scientist.
Like
what is the nature of this thought?
Where does it come from?
I mean,
then they come like bullets,
you know,
fired out of a machine gun there very,
very fast,
so to speak.
That's a quite militaristic image.
But you know,
another way is bubbles coming off the
bottom of a pot of boiling water.
You know,
if you've ever watched a pot of boiling
water,
uh,
say a glass pot,
the,
the bubbles tend to nucleate at the
bottom and then they go through the
water and they go poof at the surface.
So the thoughts are very similar and
that's when I use another,
uh,
people often use this term,
the thoughts self liberate.
You don't have to get rid of them.
People misunderstand meditation is,
Oh,
I just sweep all my thoughts away and
then I'm in this like Nirvana.
What you'll get by trying to sweep all
your thoughts away is a headache at the
most because there's no way to sweep
your thoughts away.
They will get you every time.
Uh,
and then you can have millions of
thoughts about mindfulness and
meditation and those are just thoughts
too.
They're not meditating.
But when you see that you're not your
thoughts,
then you can watch them in this kind of
impersonal,
more sort of,
if you will,
observing way with kindness,
with self compassion,
because a lot of them are heavily loaded
with negative emotion.
And you can see that if you don't touch
them,
if you don't do anything with them,
if you don't get caught in the them,
they self liberate naturally in
awareness,
the awareness,
it's like touching a soap bubble.
You know it's fun for kids and fun for
adults.
Soap bubble and you touch it and it just
goes.
Okay.
So I love that image.
So like let the thought is the soap
bubble and the emotion too.
That's you know,
balancing the thought and you don't need
to anything with it because your
awareness,
it's like if not even a finger,
it's not corporeal,
the awareness,
just the embracing of it or the arising
of it.
Like in the sky it goes poof all by
itself.
And don't take my word for it.
This is something that when you sit down
and you begin to watch,
you'll see this is not rocket science.
You can,
if you don't have to sit in a cave for
30 years to have that kind of
experience,
well you need to do is in some sense get
out of your own way.
Now I'm not saying that it's easy,
that's really hard.
But if you can have moments when you get
out of your own way,
then you'll see that a lot of this stuff
that we get so caught up and it's like
it's a mirage.
And that doesn't mean that the thoughts
aren't valuable.
I mean,
I think it was Einstein who said,
you know,
if you have one or two really good
thoughts in a lifetime,
you are ahead of the curve.
Paraphrasing.
Uh,
so most of our thoughts are actually
kind of mundane or imprisoning,
but thinking is a ferry ferry.
I mean it drives imagination,
drives creativity.
So maybe we need to just create a bigger
arena for our thoughts and watch how
they,
not only self liberate,
but also inform each other in some
sense.
And then all of a sudden you see
something that no one in the history of
humanity is seen
before
and you were apprehended
because you're making your,
or your something is being revealed to
you.
I won't say you're making the
connection,
but somehow a connection gets made.
And that's called an insight.
You're going to have profound insights.
I mean sciences,
you know,
sort of storied,
wonderful stories of Eureka moments,
insight where,
and it's usually not by driving,
thinking and banging your head against
the world's way.
And you thought as much as you've gone
as far as thought can take you,
and then you rest in awareness.
Maybe sometimes it's in sleep or you
wake up out of asleep and then no.